the european commission is recommending
that ukraine be granted formal eu
membership candidate status this will
allow kiev to start negotiations with
brussels commission president ozil from
the line added that ukraine must carry
out a number of political and economic
reforms the eu's recommendation will
then be discussed by all of the bloc's
27 nations at a summit in brussels next
week it follows an endorsement for
fast-tracking ukraine's candidacy by
four european leaders visiting here
now let's get a reaction from the
ukrainian government now joining me from
kiev is august definition she's
ukraine's deputy prime minister for
european integration uh thanks for
joining us here on dw news can i ask you
are you and your government satisfied
with the commission's recommendation
uh hello greetings deutsche welle and
all the all those who are watching uh we
nearly have a have a feeling of
celebration here of course it's far uh
not the end of the story and the
decision um to be taken on 21st but
for us it's really important that the
conclusion and the position announced by
european commission was approved
unanimously by uh the members of the
european commission and they're they're
they're very clear
messaging and understanding and um it's
also a tribute to the reforms and the
positive transformations we've been
going through for the last years and of
course clear message on granting
candidate statutes and the european
perspective for ukraine paves the way
towards uh mobilizing the unity for the
24th so of course we are
so having the commission on your side is
one thing but it's no secret that beyond
the commission some eu member states
oppose granting ukraine candidate status
as portugal is denmark the netherlands
for example so the eu summit is coming
next week do you think you can persuade
them to change their starts
well first and foremost we have to
understand the general landscape of
of
uh of the decision which is to be taken
whereas like 90
of all member states are not only like
um uh positive about uh making decisions
and granting ukraine candidate status
they are proactively insisting on that
and i'm talking here not only about the
eastern european countries yesterday
three leaders of the uh old europe
so-called like italy france and germany
were in kiev and made a clear message
that they support immediate
decision on granting ukrainian candidate
statutes as well as the irish irish
prime minister and group of the most
powerful democracies over european union
while european commission in its
decision has precisely
concerns of such countries as
netherlands and then denmark on the rule
of law and anti-corruption steps to be
done further so um
if they're like any other arguments
which will be revealed by this skeptical
countries they would be a bit of weak
and
unclear to us so we hope for unity and
we have been constantly underlining that
giving the candidate status to ukraine
is only the beginning of the way the
beginning of those conditions we should
need to become a member state
now you mentioned yesterday's a meeting
in kiev uh with macron schultz uh and
draghi
do you consider these states now uh real
ukrainian allies because in the past
they all have been criticized for
allegedly trying to accommodate vladimir
putin
well in that sense it is very important
that the physical meeting in such format
has taken place in kiev i'm sure that
these three leaders are not meeting
together in such format regularly by
themselves
with or without president zielenski so
it gave us a lot of understanding on
many issues related to military
assistance sanctions but also paving the
way towards european integration of
ukraine these leaders has been in place
when major
war crimes has been taking place and i
think if this is seen with your own eyes
if the proofs are provided to these
leaders by their own services who has
been working in this field there is a
decision to be taken whether you
undertake this commitment uh ensured by
you by your position or not i'm sure
that it is and it it will be uh already
clear by the messaging following the
formal press statement now let me
briefly ask about uh olaf shaw's
relations between ukraine and germany
were strained and frosty
recently
are you now completely
happy with the support you receive from
the german government and olaf schultz
well it's too early to make any
estimations because um a very long and
unfriend discussion has been taking
place yesterday and uh it's not a secret
that we've been um we've been captured
in a major like devastation related to
the scope and the timing of the delivery
of military assistance from germany
given the fact that germany has all the
arsenal of the most needed types of
military needed to ukraine so the
arrangements and the delivery and the
timing were
not in line with the needs to defend
ukraine and this discussion has been
taking place yesterday some
announcements were done but it is
still premature to assess it we will see
by actions not by promises
august stephanie now the deputy prime
minister for european and euro-atlantic
integration of ukraine thank you very
much for taking the time to speak to us
thank you
now our brussels bureau chief alexander
fornamen tells us why this move is so
significant
well it's definitely a very symbolic
moment this decision that was expected
today that the european commission
recommended ukraine to be granted be
granted
eu candidate status at the press
conference with us
the european commission chief is still
underway in the building right behind me
where the commission is seated and
ursula fonderline stressed already that
the assessment of the merits of
ukraine's application
has been concluded in a very careful way
that they came to the position to the
conclusion that ukraine is already on
its way to
be a part of the european family she
said that ukraine
has a very
active civil society so this is
definitely a plus and that the election
system in ukraine is free and fair and
she even went so far as saying that
ukraine has already shown its
determination to live up to european
values and standards but of course this
recommendation today is only the
beginning of what can be a very long
process
with eu leaders to decide about
ukraine's candidate status next week
when they come together here in brussels
and of course we need to to
remind our viewers that all the member
states have to be on board to grant this
status to ukraine
alexandra very briefly if you can
do you expect any resistance to the
membership bid from some uh eu states
you can never exclude that because of
course there are some member states who
are very reluctant saying that listen
this is a country
at war we cannot begin accession talks
with with
a country at war then they are also
saying that there is still a long way
for ukraine to
meet all the obligations and some of
them are saying that granting ukraine
candidate status would not be fair
considered that there are
some
states in europe that are officially
being called canada states such as
montenegro for instance or north
macedonia and they have been in the
waiting room for years now tw brussels
bureau chief alexander farnam there
thank you very much